as the Year continues to deliver a
potent slate of movies possessed of
unholy terrors and nefarious characters
and beastly delights were happy to
chronicle each and every one of them for
you these are the most disturbing movies
of 2019 director and screenwriter Dan
Gilroy last teamed up with Jake
Gyllenhaal for a caustic media satire
about an overly ambitious young man
trying to break into the gritty world of
crime journalism Nightcrawler seamlessly
blended biting satire with the
distinctly dark Sensibility even using
horror movie tropes to give the action a
nightmarish postmodern quality featuring
one of the best performances of
Gyllenhaal's career Nightcrawler proved
to be one of 2014's best films in fact
the gruesome gritty film was such a
success the pair teamed up once again
for Gilroy's latest satirical confection
the supernatural thriller velvet buzzsaw
you'll be happy to know they deliver
another scathing indictment on
capitalist culture although velvet
buzzsaw is afar campy ER and cheekier
experience I think silver hasn't been
good for him well this was done 15 years
ago Pierce was in the full bloom of
alcoholism ear the film revolves around
the fickle opportunistic world of modern
Arts we meet a vapid circle of
tastemakers out to get rich by selling
off a recently unearthed stack of
paintings the catch these paintings were
created by a madman whose Spirit resides
in each work of Arts and now the ghastly
ghoul seeks revenge against anyone who
tries profiting from his work yes the
plot is as silly as it sounds and yes
Gilroy fully embraces that silliness
throughout the film he also tempers the
mood with a heaping dose of Menace that
transforms his parody into a brooding
bloody beast of a film attention body
horror fans all body horror fans please
report to Netflix immediately and add
Richard Shepherds to perfection to your
cue immediately rest assured even the
biggest score hounds may get a little
bit more than they bargained for
when they watch Shepards harrowing
psychological thriller at the center of
this twisted tale are a pair of cello
prodigies played with sinister zeal and
sensuality by Alison Williams and Logan
browning the opening moments of the
perfection finding musicians had
dramatically different points in their
lives
Williams star has faded after she walked
away from music to care for her dying
mother meanwhile Brown
star shines bright within the music
world particularly in the eyes of the
pears hottie instructor I mean I'm sorry
am I the luckiest man in the world I
don't even drink and I feel dizzy drunk
like two most perfect students together
when Charlotte finally finds herself
free of the familial obligations she
immediately tries to work her way back
into the music world that she was forced
to leave an initial seemingly mutual
attraction between the pair quickly puts
both women on a road trip which rapidly
devolves into a body [ __ ] nightmare
that would make David Cronenberg cringe
and that's just the film's opening act
from there well things get a bit nuts
with Shepard and crew twisting the
unwieldy narrative in increasingly
unsettling ways the perfection proves
itself to be a first-rate lavishly
executed thriller with a menacing energy
that's sure to satisfy the bloodthirsty
appetites of horror fans everywhere by
now you're probably familiar with Jordan
peels pitch-perfect horror film get out
and if not well we urge you to go and
watch it immediately because it's just
as amazing as you've heard in fact peels
oscar-winning debut was so incredible
there were some very legitimate concerns
that he'd suffered the sophomore slump
that plagued so many other directors
those worries only mounted when he
announced that he'd be returning to the
horror genre firs follow-up of course
all those concerns were quickly laid to
rest when peel unleashed a bone-chilling
first trailer for us and five minutes
into the director's latest socially
conscious Fright Fest you know you're in
for something wholly original and wholly
horrific much like its predecessor us is
a bold incisive wouldíve John Rock
infection that happily wears its
influences on its sleeve and yet somehow
it still doesn't look feel or play like
any horror film you've ever seen as far
as the plot goes it's a relatively
simple tale that finds a family being
terrorized by evil versions of
themselves but much like get out peel
has much bigger fish to fry expect
plenty of narrative twists and turns
along the way
[Music]
we won't spoil anything here but you
should brace yourself for a near
suffocating sense of existential dread
and some serious bloodshed - with so
many acclaim genre offerings hitting
theaters it's safe to say we're
experiencing a Golden Age of horror
films and since Stephen King is behind
some of the biggest hits in the bunch
it's also safe to say we're living in a
golden age of King adaptations while we
anxiously wait for its chapter 2 to hit
theaters we can at least hunker down and
enjoy the grisly emotionally punishing
new adaptation of Kings best-selling
novel Pet Sematary if you remember Mary
Lambert's merciless 1989 adaptation
you're probably still suffering from
nightmares involving scalpel wielding
undead infants the film offered a gritty
form of horror that made you want a
shower after the credits rolled if
you're weary of the new Pet Sematary be
warned that it's lost none of that
grittiness but it features several
important narrative changes that are
bound to disturb and disorient you even
more the main thrust of the story
remains the same a family moves to Maine
tragic deaths ensue misguided
resurrections follow and undead mayhem
reigns what sets this mayhem apart is
that a child happens to be behind much
of the bloodletting there's a relentless
sense of atmospheric anguish throughout
Pet Sematary and the film really catches
fire once the dead start to rise the
film culminates in a horrifying
heartbreaking finale that's bound to
leave you gasping for air in the mood to
be punished have a look at dragged
across concrete starring Vince Vaughn
and Mel Gibson single red ant could mean
it faster the film stops just short of
reaching over and punching you in the
face in its committed attempt to shock
provoked and condemned whoever dares to
sit through it and the 159 minute
runtime feels even longer thanks to the
film's slow pacing dragged across
concrete takes a pulpy ultraviolent
approach to cinema depositing
narcissistic morally compromised tough
guys into a brutal and nightmarish world
Vaughn and Gibson's racist easily
corrupted cops or the face of this
particular nightmare as such the film
never seeks to make heroes or even
anti-heroes out of either of them the
film presents an incurably
ugly world
that many viewers will ultimately be
uncomfortable with but if you're looking
for an exceedingly disturbing night of
entertainment this film is definitely an
option since its founding less than a
decade ago 824 films has turned into a
bonafide
indie powerhouse they've achieved this
by producing a savvy blend of stark
human dramas like moonlight ladybird and
room and artful genre fare like ex
machina the Witch and hereditary this
year saw a 24 staying the course with
this release strategy kicking off 2019
with Lee Cronin's paranoid chiller the
hole in the ground if you've never heard
of cronin it's because the hole in the
ground is the Irish filmmakers first
feature film rest assured it's a damn
impressive debut one that finds a young
mother and her son attempting to build a
new life for themselves on the edges of
a small rural town unfortunately their
new home exists on the edge of a vast
forest and that forest contains an
ominous expansive sinkhole which may or
may not be connected to the dramatic
behavioral changes in the boy tell me
the truth I am tell me the truth I asked
Brian to me
turns out they are indeed connected and
that's not really a spoiler for one
thing this plot point becomes obvious
early on in the film plus the hole in
the ground is less concerned with
shocking twists and more intent on
building a bleak atmosphere full of fear
and paranoia Cronin and company
definitely succeed in that regard
coupling their atmospheric chills with a
haunting slow burn approach the film
culminates in a finale that feels like
the stuff of Kafka's nightmares
throughout his decades-long career
behind the camera filmmaker gas barn
away has been labeled everything from a
shameless provocateur to a cinematic
visionary as you may have guessed from
those labels his films are just as
likely to leave viewers disgusted as
they are to leave them utterly entranced
throughout his body of work no a doesn't
seem overly concerned with how viewers
react to his movies so long as the films
get some sort of reaction following its
2018 international release in the later
2019 us release it became clear that
climax marked another wild cinematic
experiment hell-bent on pushing the
boundaries of both narrative decency and
artistic ambition to be clear climax is
a technical artistic and narrative
achievement as potent as anything no way
has ever created before it's also
certain to force many viewers to run far
away at the first sign of the madness to
come the real lunacy arrives about
midway through climax right around the
time the dancing troupe at the heart of
the film discovers that their beverages
have been spiked with a powerful
narcotic that's about as much plot as
we're comfortable giving away not
because we're scared of spoiling
anything but because words simply can't
describe the hallucinatory hellscape
that Noah unleashes upon you
just know that it's often difficult to
watch the insanity unfold and it's
equally difficult to look away actor
Robert Pattinson really outdoes himself
in highlight portraying a man
desperately trying to survive alongside
his daughter while both of them are lost
deep in space believe us when we say
this film puts the psycho back in
psychosexual for those wondering how
Patterson's character wound up in the
outer reaches of the galaxy it's because
he was a very bad man on planet earth
along with several other offenders he
signed up for a radical reproductive
experiment instead of dying in prison
let it suffice to say that may have been
the wrong choice sound weird enough for
you well that's just the tip of the
iceberg this is a fantastically twisted
movie and at the center of all the
insanity is one of the best performances
of Pattinson his career the gripping
western horror film the wind finds
plenty of genuine chills within its
hushed haunted narrative the film
revolves around a homesteader left alone
amidst a sprawling prairie landscape in
the wake of an unspeakable tragedy the
culmination of that tragedy plays a
vital part in the film's overarching
narrative and the wind is at its most
effective when the woman is trapped in
total seclusion
[Music]
this is an almost perfect exercise in
psychological horror in fact the film is
so effective you're willing to overlook
the fact that certain elements of the
dialogue and storyline leaves something
to be desired hag Azusa is so slow-paced
it's bound to test the mettle of even
the fiercest horror fan but if you stick
with the film you'll eventually arrive
at one of the most gut-wrenching ly
horrific finales in recent memory set
almost entirely in the mountainous
terrain of 15th century Europe
haggis oosa follows an outcast
struggling to maintain her sanity while
living in almost total isolation with
her newborn daughter the film's pacing
effectively lols the viewer into a
trance making those bone-chilling final
moments all the more devastating it's
totally okay if you've never heard of
possum the film never got a theatrical
release stateside and after a well
received yet limited run in its native
UK in 2018 it went straight to VOD for
US markets earlier this year and after
you watch this emotionally grueling film
you'll see why the majority of viewers
will want to stay away but not you right
you're not afraid of anything
a puppet features prominently in possum
but not just any puppet this one is
shaped like a giant spider with a
monstrous human head attached and it
looks a little something like this
coupled with the film's suffocating
sense of dread possum is definitely an
exceedingly difficult film to watch
brace yourself for a harrowing tale of a
man who's damaged beyond all repair by
childhood abuse and trauma the film is
beautifully photographed and skillfully
acted but it's so relentlessly bleak it
makes David Lynch's Eraserhead and look
like a walk in the park consider
yourself warned on this one okay check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]